. IN
RETIREMENT WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY THAT'S
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY WE
ARE ANTICIPATING THE AUTHOR IN
A SECOND BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR HILL HERE
HILL HERE MOREAU. ROLL. HERE
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL. AND HERE WE OF COURSE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND WE WILL
WAIT FOR OUR AUTHOR IN IN THE
BILL PRESENTATION
. A LOT. YEAH
.
YEAH RIGHT
. REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE FULL LABOR COMMITTEE THE.
REPUBLICANS OTHER THING WELL
ALMOST YEAH. EVERY GOD WELL ALL
THE THEIR WELCOME AND YOU LIKE
2% A. B. ONE SEVENTY SIR AB ONE
SEVENTY IS. HE'S A LEGISLATION
THAT I'M PUTTING FORWARD. TO
THE NEGOTIATIONS IN THE SENATE
OVER AB FIVE I WILL NOTE THAT
IT GIVES A DELAY OF NEWSPAPERS
IN NEWSPAPER SERVICES A YEAR TO
COMPLY WITH THE AB FIVE.
REQUIREMENTS IN MEXICO. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO CLAIMS UNDER DYNAMICS
AGAINST OF LARGE NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS HELD LARGELY BY WOMEN
OF COLOR WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY MISCLASSIFIED AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE
MISCLASSIFIED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE EVER CARRIED A BILL THAT I
AM VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO BUT IN
THE SPIRIT OF GOOD FAITH. I
WILL BRING IT FORWARD. AND.
THERE YEAH VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OTHER THOSE IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JIM YOUR WITH
A CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION FOR SPOTS LIKE TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
THE AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
CHAIR THE STAFF SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ALL THE OTHER SENATORS INVOLVED
IN THIS. THIS IS GOING TO GIVE
SOME BREATHING SPACE TO
NEWSPAPERS TO FIND A WAY TO
WITHIN THEIR MEANS OUR CREATE
SYSTEMS THAT COMPORT WITH THE
VALUES THAT WERE EXPRESSED BY
THE AUTHOR IN THE PROPONENTS OF
AB FIVE. AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE AND WE'RE
CHEN ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. YOUR MEMBERS
AS ARE THE OTHER BEHALF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCT THIS
COUNCIL ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS
AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS LAID
OUT BUT ALSO NOTE THAT THIS WAS
PART OF A NEGOTIATION AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE AND WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
THAT LIKE TO COMMENT TODAY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE BRING
BACK WITH ME COMMENTS QUESTIONS
CONCERNS. INTERMITTENTLY LAWTON
I APPRECIATE THE CITY COUNT THE
CITY COUNCIL OF THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BOB THIS FORWARD IN
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION AND
CONCERNED ABOUT. WHAT THIS BILL
IN EFFECT WILL DO. I WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD SAID THE
NAME WAS REFERENCE LAB INVOLVED
IN THE CONVERSATION AND IT HAD
TO DEAL WITH THE- HUNDREDS OF
MY OWN DISTRICT ANOTHER SINCE
HIS WHAT I'LL- WEEKLIES IN
SMALL PAPERS THE ETHNIC PRESS.
ON THE VERY US WEEKLY'S. THAT
MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS MANY.
AW MONOLINGUAL CONSTITUENTS OF
MINE WHO RELY ON THE PAPERS FOR
ACCESS TO INFORMATION. IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITY ACCESS TO
INFORMATION WAYS IN WHICH THEY
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER.
INFORMATION THAT WE RELY ON
THIS PUBLIC SERVANTS TO KEEP
OUR FINGER ON THE PULSE OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND EMERGING
IN. PLEASE COMMUNITIES AS WELL
ARM WHILE APPRECIATE THAT THIS
BILL HAS CAST THE A BROAD NET
IN TERMS OF ALL OF THE
PUBLICATIONS WHO WILL HAVE BE
GIVEN THIS ONE YEAR. REPRIEVE
IF YOU WEAR. I DO HOPE THAT ALL
THE NEWSPAPERS USE THIS TIME
WISELY TO REALLY FIGURE OUT A
WAY IN WHICH THE SMALL WEEKLIES
CAN CONTINUE TO BE VIABLE SINCE
THEY ALREADY OPERATE ON A VERY
THIN MARGIN. AND WAYS IN WHICH
WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR LARGELY
ARE NO LONGER SUBJECTED TO THE
KIND OF WORK CONDITIONS THEY
DO. THIS IS A CHALLENGING
SCENARIO I APPRECIATE YOUR
PASSION AND YOUR PREFERENCE TO
NOT HAVE TO CARVE THEM OUT BUT
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH I'M
ATTEMPTING TO REPRESENT AND
ADVOCATE FOR IN THIS
CONVERSATION. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE CUT OFF. COMMUNICATING
WITH EACH OTHER AND CUT OFF
VERTICALLY IN THIS TIME
NATIONALLY THAT ARE CUT OFF.
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BE VIABLE
COMMUNITIES. FOR THOSE REASONS
I'LL BE SUPPORTED AB ONE
SEVENTY TODAY REALLY THANK YOU
SENATOR JEFF HILL AYE I ALSO
THINK. THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT A SMALL PAPERS THE
LOCAL PAPER SO PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OTHERWISE.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW I MEAN THEY
ARE THAT CRITICAL I THINK IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. BUT I
ALSO THINK THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY IN GENERAL. IS OF
RIGHT NOW IN A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME WHILE I DON'T WANT TO SEE
THEM TRY TO. RECOVER OR TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE ON THE BACKS
OF THE LOWEST PAID PEOPLE WHICH
ARE AS YOU INDICATE THAT. THE
PEOPLE WHO DO THIS KIND OF
WORK. I THINK WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE HOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IT IS THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A FREE
PRESS. AND MANY PAPERS LARGE AS
WELL AS SMALL ARE. SUFFERING
RIGHT NOW IN OUR THREATENED BY
THE INTERNET. BUT I DO THINK
THAT MOST OF OUR PAPERS HAVE
ENORMOUS VALUE. BIGGER PAPERS
THAT THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE NEWS NOT PROPAGANDA
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS ALSO
SOMETHING WE NEED TO FACTOR IN.
THAT BEING SAID I'VE ALWAYS
WONDERED WHY IT IS. I RECALL AS
A KID AND THEN EVEN MY OWN
GRANDKIDS WHO. DO PAPER ROUTES
AND END UP HAVING TO COLLECT
THE MONEY. OF FROM THE FOLKS TO
WHOM THEY DELIVER PAPERS A FIVE
IN THE MORNING. OR ELSE THEY
HAVE TO FUND THE- THEY HAVE TO
PAY THE COMPANY ITSELF. IN
OTHER WORDS THAT THEY ARE SO
INDEPENDENT THAT THEY HAVE TO
COLLECT. FROM THE READER OR
ELSE THEY HAVE TO PAY IN THE
FEW PENNIES AND NICKELS THAT
THEY HAVE MADE. IN THOSE PAPER
ROUTES AND BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEMSELVES I HOPE THAT'S GOING
TO CHANGE TO THAT SEEMS SO
INHERENTLY. UNFAIR SO I THINK
THERE IS SOME WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. OVER THE NEXT YEAR
I WANT TO PRESERVE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE FREE PRESS IT
IS CRITICAL AND MARK SEE. A
SMALL PAPERS ARE CRITICAL TO
THE WELL BEING OF COMMUNITIES.
BRENT THE THIRD CHALLENGED
MONEY IN TODAY'S WORLD BUT-
HOPEFULLY. YOU'LL BE ABLE TO DO
IT NOT ON THE BACKS OF THE- OF
THE SMALLEST THOSE WHO MAKE THE
LEAST AND WHO. FIVE IN THE
MORNING IS HARD FOR ANYBODY LET
ALONE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE.
TRYING TO JUST MAKE ENDS MEET
SO WITH THAT I WILL ALSO
SUPPORT THIS THE VEGAS
INTERJECTION. SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHORS CONCERNS
NAY THIS QUESTION FOR NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS. SO AND WE HAVE A-
BASICALLY I GUESS REPRIEVES NOT
THE RIGHT WORD WE HAVE A ONE
YEAR CONTINUATION THE CURRENT
SITUATION. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS THAT YOU
KNOW. YOU COULD COME BACK HERE
AND MAKE MANY SAME ARGUMENTS
AND SAY WE NEED MORE TIME SO
CAN YOU MAYBE SPEAK TO WHAT
KIND OF STOPS. THE INDUSTRY IS
GOING TO TAKE IN THIS PERIOD OF
TIME SO THAT WE'RE NOT BACK
HERE AGAIN HAVING OUT BECAUSE
THAT I MEAN. IT'S A ONE YEAR
RIGHT. LOTS OF OTHER INDUSTRIES
HAVE COME AND SAID WE NEED
TRANSITION TIME TO SO. BUT YEAH
DYNAMICS WAS DECISION THAT WAS
RAY MADE SO THAT'S EXISTENCE
AND- NOW SPRING COURT IS RULED
THIS BILL ACTUALLY TO ROLL BACK
IN MANY WAYS IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT MAYBE NOT AS FAR SOME PEOPLE
WANT BUT IT IS SO. WHAT IS IT.
THAT THE NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ARE GOING TO DO SO THAT WE'RE
NOT BACK HERE A YEAR. LATER
WITH THEIR REQUEST WE NEED MORE
TIME. WELL TO ASK TRUTH SENATOR
OF. A LOT OF THE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE BEEN AMONG OME OF MY
INDUSTRY FOLKS GEARING UP
TOWARD TRYING TO COMPLY WITH AB
FIVE AND WE DID LEARN THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS DELAY
UNTIL JUST RECENTLY THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE HAD AND I
KNOW THERE IS EARNESTNESS ON
THE PART OF THE PUBLISHERS TO
TRY TO FIND A WAY WITHIN THEIR
MEANS. ON TO GET SOMETHING DONE
BUT AS FOR NOW I CAN'T SAY THAT
THERE'S ANY PLAN IN PLACE PER
SE JUST GOOD FAITH THAT WERE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE TIME THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
HERE SO I'M I'M AND IS THAT I'M
I'M GONNA ASSUME WE SAY GOOD
FIT AND I BELIEVE YOU DID SAY
THAT. THERE IS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER BUS HERE. TO FOR MORE
TIME. BY A I ASSUME THAT'S THE
CASE YES OKAY APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. VERY TO US YES
SENATOR MITCHELL SORRY I WOULD
JUST WANT TO SAY IN RESPONSE TO
ONE DOCTOR PANTS POINT WHETHER
THERE'S A REQUEST OR NOT I KNOW
THAT I WILL NOT BE AN ADVOCATE
AT THE TABLE PROMOTING
ADDITIONAL TIME I'D I STEPPED
UP AND OUT. THIS TIME BASED ON
THE CONCERNS I EXPRESS TO GIVE
THE EXTRA TIME AND SO A YEAR IS
THE YEAR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
SO I HOPE THE TIME IS USED WILL
DEFINITELY. THANK YOU SIR
MITCHELL SAID SENATOR MORAN IS
NOT EXCUSE ME AND- EXPRESSED I
WILL BE AN ADVOCATE FOR.
EXTENDING OUT FURTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORAL IN SEE
NO FURTHER COMMENT YOU KNOW IT
AND IT HAS BEEN SAID AND I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
BUT- I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS TO. THE LITTLE
COMPROMISE HERE ON THAT ONE
YEAR I THINK THE- INDUSTRY IS
GOING TO PUT THEIR BEST EFFORT
INTO A SOLUTION HERE THEY HAVE
TO I DON'T BELIEVE THERE WILL
BE AN EXTENSION AND- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
THAT WE MAINTAIN. THE VIABILITY
OF THE PRINTED PRESS AS WE LOOK
AT IN SENATOR MITCHELL MADE THE
COMMENT THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED
THAT COMMUNITY ACCESS WE NEED
TO. TO BE INVOLVED IN ALLOW OUR
COMMUNITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND TO US ON THEIR
THEIR DESIRES AND THEIR NEED TO
NEW WE DON'T WANT. THEM TO ONLY
RELY ON THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND TELEVISION NEWS FOR
THEIR THEIR COVERAGE AND THE-
EXTENT OF THEIR KNOWLEDGE ON
HOW. THE SYSTEM IS IN OUR
COUNTRY'S GOING INTO AYE. THE
PUBLISHERS RECORD IS THAT AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
SOLUTION. SOMETIME DURING THIS
YEAR THAT WILL WORK FOR THEM
AND WORK FOR ALL OF US AS WELL
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO WORK. ALLOW THIS
TO HAPPEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WOULD BE LYING IF I
SAID THIS ISN'T A HEARTBREAKING
FOR ME BECAUSE THE DYNAMICS
DECISION. WAS AIMED AT. THIS
TYPE OF A. B. THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY FOR GENERATIONS
ALTHOUGH THEY NO LONGER REQUIRE
YOU TO CUT YOUR OWN MONEY.
THAT'S HOW IT WAS WHEN I WAS A
GIRL. HAVE BEEN MISSED FIND
WORKERS THEY HAVE FACED
COUNTLESS LAWSUITS UNDER DINA
ARE UNDER BROWN LOW AND HAVE
LOS THOSE. THEY. WILL CONTINUE
TO FACE LAWSUIT. I WAS
HEARTBROKEN FIND OUT THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PENDING
LAWSUITS AND NOW I UNDERSTAND
THE REASONING WHY WE COULDN'T
MAKE THIS EXEMPTION JUST FOR
THE SMALL WEEKLIES AND BASED ON
CIRCULATION NUMBERS BECAUSE OUR
LARGEST NEWSPAPERS ARE IN FACT
CURRENTLY FACING CLAIMS. WHICH
WELL AT THE BEST BE JUSTICE
DELAYED PROBABLY JUSTICE DENIED
BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUE UNDER DYNAMAX BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN.
THEY WILL BE EXEMPTED FROM
THOSE CLAIMS ARE ONCE EVEN AB
FIVE APPLIES FROM THE CLAIMS
BETWEEN THE TIME OF DYNAMAX.
AND WHEN THEY MUST COMPLY. THE
UP A POINT THAT OUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. WHEN WE DO BILLS TO
A SOMETIMES AND IT'S NOT THE
FIRST TIME IN PEACE LEGISLATION
I'VE HAD TO SWALLOW HARD AND
EXEMPTS PEOPLE WHO I FEEL LIKE
ARE AT TE CORE OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THERE'S NO
LEGITIMATE REASON BESIDES THE
FACT THAT OF. THE ENTIRE NEW
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA WEAPONIZE
THEIR EDITORIAL PAGE AGAINST
THIS BILL BASED ONLY ON
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS AND- IT'S A
LITTLE HYPOCRITICAL. BUT NAY
END AB FIVE WILL COVER A
MILLION WORKERS WHO NEED THEIR
PROTECTION. AND SO I'M WILLING
TO CARRY THIS BILL AT THAT FOR
THE RECORD WANT TO POINT OUT IT
IS A- WITH A HEAVY HEART. AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S REFLECTIVE
OF. MY RECORD IN THIS
LEGISLATURE SAMPLE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CLOTHES ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL WE
HAVE A MOTION TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BE CONCURRED IN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR HILL AYE
HILL AYE WORLD I. THANK JACKSON
FIVE JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE PAN HI. THERE IT
WE HAVE FIVE VOTERS. AND THE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED